i'll let you boy one time this week on
thug notes we getting twisted with the
catcher in the rye by jd salads
this book tells the story of holden
caulfield a 16 year old white boy who
started talking about the events
that got his ass slung up in a mental
hospital you see last christmas
holden got kicked out of his prissy
private school for flunking
all his classes accept english holla
so then he drops in on his old teacher
spencer who tells him that he got to get
his [ __ ]
together later holden rolls up to his
crib where he throws
down with this roomy strand later he'll
be macking some girl holding used to
holla at
after getting his ass whooped holding
pieces out to new york city where he
gonna lay low at the edmond
hotel now my boy comes clean to the
reader and admits he ain't never busted
his cherry even though he
said he always been swimming in shrimp
so he decided to get himself a pro named
sunny
and get his freak on when sonny rolls up
to his crib
holden chokes like a [ __ ] and said he
just wanna talk
then sonny tried to shake my boy down
for more cash but holden ain't backing
down
and kicks her ass out next thing you
know sonny's pimp maurice busses in
[ __ ] slaps hold it and jacks that paper
son
so hold and eventually decide he gonna
see his baby sister phoebe
who asks him what he want to be about
holden says he sees himself in a big
field of ride
full of kids where he be standing at the
cliff catching any little homies who
about to fall off
now when his folks come home holden
slips out to kick it with his old
teacher mr antolini
but holden got a bell when he thinks
that creepy cat be feeling on
while he's asleep at this point holden
bout to straight
loses [ __ ] so he decided to get the hell
out of dodge
his sister phoebe want to join up but he
shuts her ass
down phoebe gets all left and tells him
to shut his trap
so holden apologizes to phoebe and takes
her to the zoo where he enjoys watching
her kick it on the carousel
at this point hold and say all he want
to say he could talk about how he got
sick and locked up
but he just ain't feeling
a true player might say that catcher
illustrates how holding trying to find
stability and acceptance
in a broken society full of people that
always be faking but when that fool come
up empty-handed
he gotta get real and buck the system
now break yourself for this his simple
blood
by turning around his hunting hat hold
and be telling us that his values be the
reverse of the rest of societies
and if you roll them like a g you
probably notice that be the same way
baseball catchers wear their hat
foreshadowing his role as the catcher in
the rye and unless you peep this quote
that be explained in the title
you'd be acting like a straight phony i
keep picturing all these little kids
playing some game in this big
field of raw and i have to catch
everybody if they start to go over the
cliff
on a literal holding be saving kids from
falling off a cliff
but figuratively he's saving them from
all the bent-ass [ __ ] of adulthood
even though they ain't nothing holden
can do to stop the pure world of
children from changing to the fake ass
world of adults
he's going to bucky for himself and
other little homies for as long as he
can so when holden preaching about the
glass cases up in the museum
what he really saying is that he don't
want to join the ranks of them fake ass
adults he want to freeze time
just like the plastic players behind the
glass that's why the only one he can
keep it real with is his baby sister
phoebe but that ain't cutting it hold
and be tripping cause he got a legit
desire to search for beauty and human
contact
but just ain't finding it in a world of
such ugliness this is what makes holding
one of the loneliest players in all of
literature
he keeps it so real while everybody else
front
but as much as hold and be spitting that
righteous talk he's sure as hell ain't
no prince like he said
i'm the most terrific lie you ever saw
in your life and although he wants you
to think he hard
homeboy got a gentle soul that's why he
always asking what them ducks in the
central park lake gonna do once the
water freezes over
so in the end this gangster pays the
price for being too soft in the world
twisted by the seat
by spending his days in a psych ward
damn
yo thanks for checking in i'll catch you
next week my well-read ballers